ان كل كل نوعيه في المجتمع كل شخص في
المجتمع له له فضيله وهي معروفه معروفه
ليست من انا فقط
بنوع من انواع المداعبه ادخلت الاخيره
لماذا لماذا قلت انه فضيله رجل الدين
الصمت انا اعتقد انه التقوى ها هنا حينما
تجد رجال الدين في مرحله معينه ونمت
امتداد العالم العربي للامانه
يصرخون ويمارسون نوع من انواع العنصر
اللفظي والعنف المادي
ويسحل الناس والشوارع في ايران وفي
باكستان في حتى في باكستان
وعندنا هنا كلنا نعرف ماذا جرى وفي مصر
اغتيالات وفي المغرب فهذا بالنسبه لي ليس
ليس هو التدين الذي
اعرفه وعشنا عليه نحن في القرى وقلتها
اكثر من مره اقرب ما يكون الى ما نسميه
كما شبهته مثل الاكسجين كل يوم في الهواء
لكن لا نراه وبالتالي حينما يصمت رجال
الدين عن هذه الثرثره عن هذا الخطاب
العنيف هم يسهمون في السلم الاجتماعي
ويشكلون قدوه اددوك التبادل هددوك في فتره
من فترات طبعا كثيرين من الحقيقه لست وحدي
يعني في معرض الكتاب ابو المساعده اعتقد
في التلفزيون يكسر
الاصنام ونكسر راسك وراسل الذين يخالفون
معتقداتنا يعني تخيل هذه 1400 سنه
موجوده في في العراق وفي افغانستان وحتى
ربما في في مناطق اخرى حتى في الحجاز ربما
يكون في بقايا معين ولم يكسر احد وياتي
هؤلاء الناس ويكسرون هذه الاعمال الفنيه
الجماليه التي كنت ادرس بعض صورها في ماده
علم الجمال ويقول لي انها تهدد مقدسات
الامه يعني نؤمن انواع الجنون خطاب الجنون
ولا استغرب من الخطاب الجنون يولد مثل هذا
العنف وهناك ايضا حتى في القريه يعني لا
اريد ان اخذ في التواصيل لكني سمعت
تهديدات من هذا النوع واحمد والله انها
كانت كانت
يعني زوبعات في فنجان واهني استغل هذه
الفرصه واهني الجيل الجديد والجيل القادم
بهذه الروح السلميه الانسانيه
العقلانيه التي بدات تشييع في مجتمعنا
وانا احيانا كثيره واسمح لي هذا الاستطراد
حينما اخرج الى الرياض
واتمشى هنا او هناك واعود البيت بدون ما
اسمع عدوان لفظي على الناس او عدواننا
اشعر انني في مدينه معرفه وفكر وسلام
وليست مدينه عنف
وقلق ووتر كما عشت فيها